Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I am the final war chief, never defeated in battle. Lakota, remember my name. Now on this walk my bones and my heart are warm in the hands of my father. Wakantanka has shown me the shadows will break near the creek called Wounded Knee. Remember my name, Lakota. I am the final war chief. Father, my heart never defeated in battle.
感谢收听《历史的余味》（The Rest Is History）。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我是最后的战争酋长，从未在战斗中被击败。拉科塔人，记住我的名字。现在，在这段旅程中，我的骨骼和心脏在父亲的手中感到温暖。瓦坎坦卡（Wakantanka）向我展示了阴影将在名为“伤膝河”（Wounded Knee）的小溪附近消散。记住我的名字，拉科塔人。我是最后的战争酋长。父亲，我的心脏从未在战斗中被击败。
Father, my bones never defeated in battle. Leave them at Wounded Knee. And remember our name, Lakota. I am released from shadow. My horse dreams and dances under me as I enter the actual world. So those are the final lines of The Death of Crazy Horse, a poem by Lucille Clifton, who was one of the most prominent black poets of the 1970s and 80s, twice a Pulitzer finalist.
父亲，我的骨骼从未在战斗中被击败。把它们留在伤膝河。记住我们的名字，拉科塔人。我已从阴影中解脱。当我进入真实世界时，我的马在梦中起舞。以上就是露西尔·克利夫顿（Lucille Clifton）的诗作《疯马之死》（The Death of Crazy Horse）的最后几行。她是20世纪70和80年代最杰出的黑人诗人之一，曾两次入围普利策奖决赛。
And Dominic, she was a native of Buffalo, New York. So I wonder if that possibly explains her interest in the culture of the Lakota. Maybe. It's interesting, isn't it? Because I think she's obviously an African-American poet, or was an African-American poet. And it's interesting because it reflects the extent to which Crazy Horse himself had become a sort of legend of resistance to white America in the 70s and 80s. And the other thing is that poem also
多米尼克，她是纽约州布法罗市人。所以我很好奇，这是否能解释她对拉科塔文化的兴趣。也许吧。这很有趣，不是吗？因为我认为她显然是一位非裔美国诗人，或者说曾经是一位非裔美国诗人。这很有趣，因为它反映了疯马本人在70和80年代已经成为一种反抗美国白人统治的传奇。还有一点是，那首诗也
points forward to the events, the tragedy at Wounded Knee in 1890, which we will come on to, which is often seen as the terrible climax of the whole story. Yeah, where hearts are buried. Exactly, where hearts are buried at Wounded Knee. So yes, that sort of intersection of Crazy Horse, of Wounded Knee and the fate of the Plains Indians more generally, and this idea of resistance to kind of white Anglo-Saxon capitalism, I guess. I mean, I think it, which we've touched on earlier, but I think it points to why Crazy Horse has a particular reputation and status that even Sitting Bull doesn't have, for reasons we will be exploring, not just in this episode, but in the final episode as well. Yes, definitely.
指向了1890年伤膝河的悲剧事件，我们稍后会讲到，这通常被视为整个故事的可怕高潮。是的，那是心灵埋葬的地方。没错，心灵埋葬在伤膝河。所以，疯马、伤膝河以及平原印第安人的命运，再加上这种对盎格鲁-撒克逊资本主义的反抗思想，我想这正是我们之前提到的，也解释了为什么疯马拥有连坐牛（Sitting Bull）都没有的特殊声望和地位，其原因我们不仅会在本集探讨，也会在最后一集中深入分析。是的，绝对是这样。
But we are in the immediate aftermath of the Battle of the Little Bighorn, which Custer had his last stand, or did he, in the previous episode. And it is a great, astonishing victory for the Lakota and their various allies, the greatest congregation, the greatest assemblage of Plains Indians, probably of all time.. And yet for them, it's a disaster, isn't it? Yeah, that's the irony, isn't it? So we ended last time with news of the defeat, traveling back to Philadelphia, where they're having the centennial exhibition, the celebration of the nation's birthday. And of course, for the Americans, it's seen as this seismic, couldn't be more symbolic humiliation. But for the Lakota, it is their last stand.
但我们现在处于小大角战役（Battle of the Little Bighorn）的余波中，卡斯特（Custer）在那里进行了最后的抵抗，或者说他在上一集中是这样做的。对于拉科塔人及其盟友来说，这是一场伟大而惊人的胜利，这是平原印第安人有史以来最伟大的集结。然而对他们来说，这却是一场灾难，不是吗？是的，这就是讽刺之处，对吧？所以我们上次以战败的消息传回费城结束，当时他们正在举办百年博览会，庆祝国家的生日。当然，对美国人来说，这被视为一种极具象征意义的、震撼性的羞辱。但对拉科塔人来说，这是他们的最后抵抗。
That's the terrible irony of it. They've won this great battle and they have moved off. If you remember, they moved off before the relief force arrived to rescue Bentin and Reno on the top of their hill. But they don't stay together. So almost straight away, I mean, they move for about 150 miles. They know they've won. They're very pleased with themselves. Obviously, they've won. They're very pleased with themselves.
这就是可怕的讽刺。他们赢得了这场伟大的战斗，然后撤离了。如果你还记得的话，他们在救援部队赶到山顶营救本廷（Bentin）和里诺（Reno）之前就撤离了。但他们并没有聚在一起。所以几乎立刻，我是说，他们移动了大约150英里。他们知道自己赢了。他们对自己非常满意。显然，他们赢了。他们对自己非常满意。
Obviously, they're celebrating. They're mourning their dead. But they have a big council when they're about 150 miles away from Little Bighorn. And they make what I think is a completely understandable decision, probably the only decision they would ever, I mean, they had to make such a decision, but it's fatal, which is splitting up. So they divide their forces. And they do that partly, don't they? Because there's not enough buffalo left to feed all of
显然，他们在庆祝。他们在哀悼死者。但当他们距离小大角约150英里时，他们召开了一次大型会议。他们做出了一个我认为完全可以理解的决定，可能也是他们唯一能做的决定，但这个决定是致命的，那就是分散开来。所以他们分开了部队。他们这样做部分是因为没有足够的野牛来喂养他们所有人，对吧？
them. But doesn't it also reflect a kind of innocence, the notion that they just want to be left alone and go their own way? Totally. Because thinking about it, what's their plan there? What's their end game, their strategy? And actually the truth is they haven't got one. Because even if they had stayed together they would still have been defeated you know the americans would finally have marshaled enough troops to overcome them were they going to win a war and carve out a kind of nation state of their own clearly that was never going to happen because it is a seismic shock and as we know when america gets a seismic shock. And as we know, when America gets a seismic shock, whether it's Pearl Harbor or 9-11 or whatever, the calls for replying with overwhelming military force are overwhelming. And so the generals who have been trying to defeat the Plain Indians, they're now in a position to
但这是否也反映了一种天真，即他们只是想被留下来，走自己的路？完全是这样。因为仔细想想，他们的计划是什么？他们的终局、他们的策略是什么？事实上，他们根本没有计划。因为即使他们聚在一起，他们最终还是会被击败，你知道的，美国人最终会集结足够的军队来战胜他们。他们打算赢得一场战争并开辟一个属于自己的民族国家吗？显然那永远不会发生。因为这是一个震撼性的冲击，正如我们所知，当美国受到震撼性冲击时，无论是珍珠港事件还是9/11事件，要求以压倒性军事力量进行回击的呼声都是压倒性的。所以那些一直试图击败平原印第安人的将军们，现在处于一个位置，可以
say, well, see, we need more resources. That's exactly it. So even as the Plains Indians, so the Cheyennes have gone to the Powder River country, most of the Dakotas have gone down to the Little Missouri and they've split up into their different groups. So the Hunkpapas, the Oglalas and so on and so forth. They've completely fragmented in the weeks after Little Big Horn. But while that is happening, the generals who have heard the news of Custer's defeat are telling reporters, OK, the gloves are off now. So General Sherman. No more Mr. Nice Guy. okay the gloves are off now so general sherman no more mr nice guy yeah he says to a reporter we will hunt them down and corral them on reservations we will either do that now or
说，好吧，看，我们需要更多资源。正是如此。所以，当平原印第安人——夏延人去了粉河（Powder River）地区，大多数达科他人去了小密苏里河（Little Missouri），他们分裂成了不同的群体。所以洪克帕帕人（Hunkpapas）、奥格拉拉人（Oglalas）等等。他们在小大角战役后的几周内完全分裂了。但与此同时，听到卡斯特战败消息的将军们正在告诉记者，好吧，现在要动真格的了。所以谢尔曼将军（General Sherman）说，不再做“好人”了。好吧，现在要动真格的了，所以谢尔曼将军说，不再做“好人”了。是的，他告诉记者，我们将把他们追捕并围困在保留地里，我们要么现在就做，要么
we will exterminate them that is where we are now and sheridan who has been i mean don't forget all these generals have been pressing for 10 years or more to have more resources in the army because the army has been cut back so much since the end of the civil war so sheridan and sherman go to congress and they say right now you have to give us what we want we want a bigger army we want more forts in the middle of the unceded indian territory and we want to have military control of the indian agencies all these quakers and whatnot you know trying to run the agencies. That's a shambles.
我们将消灭他们，这就是我们现在的处境。而谢里丹（Sheridan）——别忘了，所有这些将军十多年来一直都在要求军队获得更多资源，因为内战结束后军队被削减得太多了——所以谢里丹和谢尔曼去国会说，现在你们必须给我们想要的，我们要一支更大的军队，要在未割让的印第安领地建立更多堡垒，我们要对印第安事务局拥有军事控制权，那些贵格会教徒什么的，你知道，试图管理这些机构。那简直是一团糟。
Yeah. Let us do this. We're military men. We will sort this out. We will sort out your mess effectively. So Congress gives them a lot more money. Congress gives two of the agencies to military control, the Red Cloud and Spotted Tail agencies.
是的。让我们来做这件事。我们是军人。我们会解决这个问题。我们实际上会清理你们的烂摊子。所以国会给了他们更多的钱。国会把两个机构交给了军事控制，即红云（Red Cloud）和斑尾（Spotted Tail）机构。
It recruits thousands of new volunteers. So they're called the Custer avengers aren't they the custer avengers i know it couldn't be more resonant could it they recruit uh new indian auxiliaries and they basically say to general sheridan right crack on do it as you like forget about all the previous treaties and deals you do what needs to be done so effectively they are weaponizing custer's defeat yes totally absolutely they are now meanwhile there's a political dimension to this so in august 1876 that's a few weeks after the battle of the little big horn uh president grant signs a new law and
它招募了数千名新志愿者。所以他们被称为“卡斯特复仇者”，对吧？“卡斯特复仇者”，我知道，这再贴切不过了，不是吗？他们招募了新的印第安辅助部队，他们基本上对谢里丹将军说，好吧，放手去做吧，随心所欲，忘记之前所有的条约和协议，做需要做的事。所以实际上，他们正在将卡斯特的战败武器化。是的，完全绝对是这样。现在，与此同时，这背后有一个政治层面，所以在1876年8月，也就是小大角战役几周后，格兰特总统（President Grant）签署了一项新法律，
this is as follows there will be more rations for the plainsains Indians. So those on the reservations will get more food. Basically, Durant says, let's be frank about this. We've been pussyfooting around this for too long. The buffalo is gone. That is finished. You are going to have to rely on us totally now. But the quid pro quo is you can't go roaming and hunting. That is dead. And you have to give up your claim to all of that so-called unceded Indian land. And that includes the Black Hills, doesn't it? It does. Which is where Crazy Horse has gone with his troop. Exactly. So all of that territory, that sort of vast wilderness, I mean, I say wilderness, probably the wrong word. Which they had been promised. Which they had been promised, effectively. That's ours now. you can forget about that you've blown it you know the battle of the big horn was
内容如下：平原印第安人将获得更多口粮。所以那些在保留地的人将得到更多食物。基本上，格兰特说，坦率地说，我们在这件事上已经拖延太久了。野牛已经消失了。那已经结束了。你们现在必须完全依赖我们。但交换条件是你们不能再四处游荡和狩猎。那已经死了。你们必须放弃对所有所谓“未割让印第安土地”的权利要求。这包括黑山（Black Hills），对吧？确实包括。疯马带着他的部队去了那里。没错。所以所有这些领土，那种广阔的荒野——我说是荒野，可能用词不当——他们曾被承诺拥有的。他们曾被承诺拥有的，实际上。现在那是我们的了。你们可以忘记那些了，你们搞砸了，你知道，大角战役是
too much and if you don't surrender you just won't get any rations at all and you will starve that's what grant says and what happens is after a lot of palaver and back and forth red cloud yeah so remember red cloud from previous episodes you previously a great warrior, now much more of a moderate. But also, Dominic, crucially, a man who has been to Washington and seen what is there in the East. So he knows what he's up against in a way that perhaps other leaders don't. Yeah. He's seen the panoply of American power, but somebody like Crazy Horse, he hasn't. So it's easy to hold out, I suppose, when you're deluding yourselves about the scale of the forces ranged against you. There's a story that some chiefs, at least one chief, covered his face with a blanket while signing this deal because he knew that what they were giving away was everything, really. That they're basically giving up the whole lot.
太过分了。如果你们不投降，你们就根本得不到任何口粮，你们会饿死。这就是格兰特所说的。经过一番争论和反复，红云——是的，还记得之前几集里的红云吗？以前是一位伟大的战士，现在更像是一个温和派。但多米尼克，关键在于，他是一个去过华盛顿并亲眼见过东方世界的人。所以他知道自己面对的是什么，而其他领导人可能并不清楚。是的。他见过美国力量的排场，但像疯马这样的人，他没有见过。所以，我想，当你对自己所面对的力量规模抱有幻想时，坚持下去很容易。有一个故事说，至少有一位酋长在签署这份协议时用毯子遮住了脸，因为他知道他们放弃的是一切，真的。他们基本上放弃了所有东西。
Because they're not just giving up land, are they? They're giving up their whole way of life. They are indeed. They are indeed. There's a story that another one of the real big cheeses in the Lakota world is a guy called Spotted Tail. So one of the agencies is named after Spotted Tail. Spotted Tail said, every time this happens, you know, you say, if you don't sign, you'll get nothing to eat. You blackmail us every single time. Whenever we don't agree, you always reply, you won't get anything to eat. You won't get nothing to eat. You blackmail us every single time. Whenever we don't agree, you always reply, you won't get anything to eat, you won't get anything to eat.
因为他们不仅仅是放弃土地，对吧？他们放弃了整个生活方式。他们确实如此。确实如此。还有一个故事说，拉科塔世界里另一位真正的大人物是一个叫斑尾的人。所以其中一个机构是以斑尾命名的。斑尾说，每次发生这种情况，你知道，你们就说，如果不签字，就没饭吃。你们每次都在勒索我们。每当我们不同意时，你们总是回答，你们什么也吃不到。你们什么也吃不到。你们每次都在勒索我们。每当我们不同意时，你们总是回答，你们什么也吃不到，你们什么也吃不到。
And he has this big rant and then he picks up the pen and he signs anyway because he has no choice. It's a very sad scene. So the Black Hills are gone and the Great Sioux Reservation, a third of it is gone like that and the unceded Indian territory is gone as well. And then the generals do something very canny, very kind of ruthless and canny. They depose Red Cloud as the great sort of head chief and they say to Spotted Tail, you are the big cheese now. So that's basically, let's make an example of Red Cloud
他大发了一通牢骚，然后还是拿起笔签了字，因为他别无选择。这是一个非常悲伤的场景。所以黑山没了，大苏族保留地（Great Sioux Reservation）三分之一也没了，未割让的印第安领地也没了。然后将军们做了一些非常精明、非常冷酷且精明的事情。他们罢免了红云作为伟大的最高酋长，并对斑尾说，你现在是老大。所以这基本上就是，让我们拿红云做个榜样，
and getting Spotted Tail in on side. But also dabbling his fingers in the blood of of the whole deal yeah and they say all your supporters can keep their guns but only red clouds followers they have to give up their guns and by saying that the others can keep their guns it drives a wedge between them of course and so what you have after that is you actually have so-called reservation lakotas who had previously been have so-called reservation Lakotas who had previously been quite close to the Lakotas who were the holdouts, the hardliners. And in fact, many had fought at the battle.
并让斑尾参与进来。但也让他沾染了整个交易的血腥味，是的。他们说，你们所有的支持者都可以保留枪支，但只有红云的追随者必须交出枪支。通过说其他人可以保留枪支，这在他们之间打入了一个楔子，当然。所以在那之后，你实际上有了所谓的“保留地拉科塔人”，他们之前曾与那些坚持抵抗的强硬派拉科塔人关系密切。事实上，许多人还参加了那场战斗。
They had. Now they start to sign up with the government. The government is basically the carrot and stick. And this is the carrot. The government says, you can keep your guns. We'll give you food. We'll look after you. You just sign up with us now and we'll fight against those rebels.
他们参加了。现在他们开始与政府签约。政府基本上是胡萝卜加大棒。这就是胡萝卜。政府说，你们可以保留枪支。我们会给你们食物。我们会照顾你们。你们现在只要和我们签约，我们就会去对抗那些叛军。
Because there is this irony, isn't there, that Red Cloud says of Crook, he at least never lied to us. Yeah. And that must taste like ash in his mouth. But he's also, I mean, his nickname is Grey Wolf, isn't it? That he hunts, he's cunning, he pulls down his quarry. Yeah. And after his reverse at the Rosebud, they call him kind of the squaw general. Now he's back in full lupine mode.
因为这里有一个讽刺，不是吗？红云谈到克鲁克（Crook）时说，他至少从未对我们撒谎。是的。那一定让他感到苦涩。但他也——我是说，他的绰号是“灰狼”，对吧？他狩猎，他狡猾，他捕获猎物。是的。在玫瑰花蕾（Rosebud）战役失利后，他们称他为“娘娘腔将军”。现在他又回到了完全的狼性模式。
Exactly right. He recruits warriors from eight different tribes. And the really interesting thing is this is the first time some of those warriors have ever fought together. So some historians say the great irony is there was only one time when the Plains Indians were united, and it was when Crook and Sheridan and the other generals united them to fight for them, for the US Army, against Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse and Co., who were the kind of the holdouts who are still wandering goodness knows where, because they're searching for them. And actually Sheridan brings in a new commander who actually, Tom, I have to say I'd never really heard of before researching this story, called Nelson A. Miles. And Nelson A. Miles is like Custer, but much better, which is why we haven't heard of him because he's not
完全正确。他从八个不同的部落招募了战士。真正有趣的是，这是其中一些战士第一次并肩作战。所以一些历史学家说，最大的讽刺是，平原印第安人只有一次团结起来，那就是当克鲁克、谢里丹和其他将军联合他们，为美国陆军而战，去对抗坐牛、疯马等人时，他们是那些仍然在不知何处游荡的坚持抵抗者。实际上，谢里丹带来了一位新指挥官，汤姆，我必须说，在研究这个故事之前我从未听说过，叫纳尔逊·A·迈尔斯（Nelson A. Miles）。纳尔逊·A·迈尔斯就像卡斯特，但要好得多，这就是为什么我们没听说过他，因为他没有
killed in a sort of disastrous last stand. He'd been friends with Custer. He's incredibly ambitious, as Custer is, and driven. And he's married to Sherman's niece. He's a Civil War hero. And Miles, he's cut in the sort of, from the same cloth as Sheridan and Sherman. So he is really ruthless. I think he ends up head of the entire US Army. He does. Yeah.
死于一场灾难性的最后抵抗。他曾是卡斯特的朋友。他和卡斯特一样雄心勃勃，充满干劲。他娶了谢尔曼的侄女。他是内战英雄。迈尔斯，他和谢里丹、谢尔曼是同一类人。所以他真的很冷酷。我想他最终成为了整个美国陆军的最高长官。他确实做到了。是的。
He has the brilliant career that Custer had rather hoped that he might have. He has Custer's dream career, really. I mean, actually, Miles even fancied himself as a presidential candidate later on in life. So, you know, he has Custer's dream career, but because he's so successful. Yeah, we don't hear about him. Nobody's ever heard of him. It's so ironic. Anyway, so he leads a winter campaign.
他拥有了卡斯特曾希望拥有的辉煌职业生涯。他拥有卡斯特梦想的职业生涯，真的。我是说，实际上，迈尔斯后来甚至想过自己成为总统候选人。所以，你知道，他拥有卡斯特梦想的职业生涯，但因为他太成功了。是的，我们没听说过他。从来没人听说过他。这太讽刺了。总之，他领导了一场冬季战役。
He makes sure his men are really well equipped. Dominic, he can do a winter campaign because he has a bear coat. And this is what they call him, bear coat. They call him bear coat. Yes, you're right. I mean, I think the very fact that he has a bear coat, that alone is not enough. But it conveys a sense that he's concerned for winter wear. He is.
他确保他的士兵装备精良。多米尼克，他能进行冬季战役，因为他有一件熊皮大衣。这就是他们称呼他的名字，“熊皮大衣”。他们叫他“熊皮大衣”。是的，你是对的。我是说，我认为他有一件熊皮大衣这一事实本身并不足以说明什么。但这传达了一种他关心冬季装备的感觉。他确实关心。
And he makes sure his men are... I mean, Congress has voted them more money now because they are out for revenge. So they're a better shot and they're better equipped and all that kind of thing. So Miles is pursuing Sitting Bull through the nothingness, through the plains. And eventually on the morning of the 20th of October, so what are we, about four or five months after the Battle of the Little Bighorn, he overtakes Sitting Bull's sort of encampment in what is now southern Montana. And Sitting Bull says, well, we'll have a council.
他确保他的士兵……我是说，国会现在给他们投了更多的钱，因为他们一心想复仇。所以他们枪法更好，装备也更好，诸如此类。所以迈尔斯正在虚无中、在平原上追捕坐牛。最终在10月20日的早晨，也就是小大角战役后大约四五个月，他在现在的蒙大拿州南部追上了坐牛的营地。坐牛说，好吧，我们开个会议吧。
So they have this kind of council. Sitting Bull's all wrapped up in a buffalo robe and Miles is all in his big bear coat. Just wondering, I mean, Sitting Bull is the guy who has inflicted this devastating defeat and killed the most famous military man in America. And they're not going after to kill them. I mean, they're going after to negotiate. That seems quite striking. They're smart people.
所以他们进行了这种会议。坐牛裹着一件野牛皮长袍，迈尔斯穿着他的大熊皮大衣。我只是在想，我是说，坐牛是那个造成了毁灭性失败并杀死了美国最著名军人的人。他们不是去杀他的。我是说，他们是去谈判的。这看起来相当引人注目。他们是聪明人。
They're a long way from congressional pressure, from political pressure, and from East Coast newspapers. So they can make decisions as they see fit. It would take a long time for the news to travel back. So I don't think they feel the same urgent sort of pressure of public opinion that a general would now under the same conditions. They have a little bit more latitude, I think, and they're smart. It just seems striking that we're going to be talking a lot about US military atrocities, but it is striking that it's not like the hunt for Osama bin Laden or anything.
他们远离国会的压力、政治压力和东海岸的报纸。所以他们可以根据自己的判断做出决定。消息传回去需要很长时间。所以我认为他们并没有感受到现在将军在同样条件下所感受到的那种紧迫的公众舆论压力。我认为他们有更多的回旋余地，而且他们很聪明。我们即将谈论很多关于美国军事暴行的内容，但令人震惊的是，这并不像追捕奥萨马·本·拉登那样。
No. They're sitting down and having a chat with the guy who commanded the army that killed Custer. But is that not, Tom, to an extent because they deep down recognize that, I mean, they've said so many times, if I were in their shoes, I would do the same. Yeah, I think that must be part of it. I mean, much as they talk about the so-called savagery of the native peoples, they don't demonize them to the extent that, let's say, the Japanese would be demonized after 1941. People don't talk about them the same way as they talk about Osama bin Laden and Al-Qaeda in the 2000s. But maybe it's more a civilian thing, because it is striking how the high command, even while they're pursuing this ruthless policy, again and again, they do kind of almost, I mean, by the end, they're expressing regret. Yeah. And by the way, it works both ways. So Sheridan and Crook will both, by the end, be saying, oh, we've done,
不。他们坐下来和那个指挥了杀死卡斯特的军队的人聊天。但汤姆，这在某种程度上不是因为他们内心深处认识到——我是说，他们已经说过很多次了，如果我处在他们的位置，我也会做同样的事。是的，我想那一定是其中的一部分。我是说，尽管他们谈论所谓原住民的“野蛮”，但他们并没有像1941年后日本人被妖魔化那样去妖魔化他们。人们谈论他们的方式与2000年代谈论奥萨马·本·拉登和基地组织的方式不同。但也许这更多是平民的事情，因为令人震惊的是，高级指挥部即使在执行这种冷酷政策时，一次又一次地，他们几乎——我是说，到最后，他们表达了遗憾。是的。顺便说一句，这在双方都适用。所以谢里丹和克鲁克到最后都会说，哦，我们所做的事情，
you know, it's terrible what's happened. That thing you said about them saying they trust Crook, I think it works both ways because I think the native leaders, you see it again and again, that they will say, well, at least general so-and-so is a person you can do business with. They don't lie to us like the politicians lie to us. I think there is a modicum of respect maybe between the two sides. Yeah. I just thought it was worth flagging up. No, it's a really good point. So anyway, Miles says to Sitting Bull, look, my job is to bring you back to the reservation. You can't be roaming around anymore. Those days are gone. So Sitting Bull is furious and says, yeah, that's not going
你知道，发生的事情太可怕了。关于他们说信任克鲁克的那件事，我认为这在双方都适用，因为我认为原住民领导人，你一次又一次地看到，他们会说，好吧，至少某某将军是一个你可以与之做生意的人。他们不像政客那样对我们撒谎。我认为双方之间可能存在一点尊重。是的。我只是觉得值得提一下。不，这是一个很好的观点。总之，迈尔斯对坐牛说，听着，我的工作是带你回保留地。你不能再四处游荡了。那些日子结束了。所以坐牛很愤怒，说，是的，那不会
to happen. I'm never coming back to the reservation. He says, the white man never lived who loved an Indian and no true Indian ever lived that did not hate the white man. God Almighty made me an Indian and he didn't make me an agency Indian and he didn't intend me to be one. And Miles says to him, this is madness. If you do not come, we will exterminate you, basically. They have another meeting the next day. Miles is really struck by how miserable Sitting Bull is. It's some months after the battle now. The excitement has worn off.
发生的。我永远不会回到保留地。他说，白人中从来没有爱过印第安人的，也没有真正的印第安人是不恨白人的。上帝创造了我成为印第安人，他没有让我成为保留地的印第安人，他也不打算让我成为那样的人。迈尔斯对他说，这是疯狂的。如果你不来，我们基本上会消灭你。第二天他们又开了一次会。迈尔斯对坐牛的悲惨程度感到非常震惊。现在距离战斗已经过去几个月了。兴奋感已经消退。
The game is very hard to find. They're hungry. Winter is coming. They are miserable. Miles writes to his wife and he says he appeared much depressed, suffering from nervous excitement and the loss of power. At times he was almost inclined to accept the situation, but I think partly from fear, which is interesting, and partly from the belief that he might do better, he did not accept, but I think that many of his people were desirous to make peace. I mean, this is the thing, isn't
猎物很难找到。他们很饿。冬天要来了。他们很悲惨。迈尔斯写信给他的妻子说，他看起来非常沮丧，遭受着神经紧张和权力丧失的折磨。有时他几乎倾向于接受现状，但我认为部分出于恐惧——这很有趣——部分出于他可能做得更好的信念，他没有接受，但我认为他的许多族人渴望和平。我是说，这就是重点，不是吗？
it? You said they just want to be left alone really deep down i think an awful lot of sitting bull and crazy horses followers they really would just like things to go back to how they were well we'll see that won't we with the ghost dance yeah great yearning is for the buffalo to come back exactly and for the ways to have been what they were but of course there's never going to happen that's the tragedy so the talks break up there's actually a bit of a skirmish. It's very clear that the natives, in all this trudging here and there, a lot of them have lost their fighting spirit, as it were. Some of them actually do surrender to Miles. So Sitting Bull's alliance breaks up a bit. And what follows in the next few months, I mean, we don't need to go through every bit of it, is that actually they fragment further and further as Miles and Crook wage this relentless
你说他们内心深处只是想被留下来，我认为坐牛和疯马的许多追随者真的只是想让事情回到原来的样子。好吧，我们会看到的，不是吗？通过“鬼舞”（Ghost Dance）。是的，伟大的渴望是野牛回来，完全正确，让生活方式回到原来的样子。但当然，那永远不会发生，这就是悲剧。所以谈判破裂了，实际上发生了一点小冲突。很明显，原住民在所有这些四处奔波的过程中，很多人已经失去了战斗精神。他们中的一些人确实向迈尔斯投降了。所以坐牛的联盟有点瓦解了。在接下来的几个月里，我是说，我们不需要经历每一个细节，实际上他们进一步分裂，因为迈尔斯和克鲁克在冬天的暴风雪中进行了这种无情的
pursuit through the blizzards and the snows of winter. They are cold, they are miserable. There's a terrible story about a group of Northern Cheyenne who had been big allies of the Lakota. Crook catches up with them at something called the Dull Knife Fight in November. That's bad, isn't it? You don't want to be in a dull knife fight. Yeah. Their village is totally destroyed. The Cheyenne village is totally destroyed. Lots of them are killed. Lots of historians say pretty much all of their heritage is in this village. This village is where they keep all their stuff and they travel around with it. Their war bonnets, their buffalo hides, their holy relics.
追捕。他们很冷，他们很悲惨。有一个关于一群北夏延人的可怕故事，他们曾是拉科塔人的重要盟友。克鲁克在11月的一场名为“钝刀之战”（Dull Knife Fight）中追上了他们。那很糟糕，不是吗？你不想卷入钝刀之战。是的。他们的村庄被彻底摧毁了。夏延人的村庄被彻底摧毁了。他们中的许多人被杀。许多历史学家说，他们几乎所有的遗产都在这个村庄里。这个村庄是他们存放所有东西的地方，他们带着这些东西四处奔波。他们的战帽、野牛皮、神圣的遗物。
That is what is happening. Their past is being destroyed. Yeah. And it's all burned. It's put to the torch. Their ability to conserve who they are, the people they have been, is being deliberately annihilated. That's right. They're pretty much freezing. Lots of them surrender. And then what happens to the Cheyenne is really instructive. So they surrender to a crook and he says, right, you're going off to a reservation. And that reservation is not in Montana or Wyoming or the Dakotas. It's in Oklahoma. It is hundreds of miles away. They're sent off to this reservation. There are other Cheyenne at this reservation, but they're Southern Cheyenne. The Southern Cheyenne say to them, who the hell are you? Oh, we're Cheyenne too. And they're like, no, you're not. You're Lakotas. You've gone Lakota, basically. And they realize that effectively, they've lost their rootedness. They've lost all their heritage. Their own brethren don't really recognize them. Well, that's the paradox, isn't it? That their nomadic nature has been
这就是正在发生的事情。他们的过去正在被摧毁。是的。而且一切都被烧毁了。它被付之一炬。他们保存自己是谁、他们曾经是什么样的人的能力正在被蓄意消灭。没错。他们几乎快冻僵了。他们中的许多人投降了。然后夏延人的遭遇真的很有启发性。所以他们向克鲁克投降，他说，好吧，你们要去保留地。那个保留地不在蒙大拿州、怀俄明州或达科他州。它在俄克拉荷马州。它在数百英里之外。他们被送往这个保留地。这个保留地里还有其他夏延人，但他们是南夏延人。南夏延人对他们说，你们到底是谁？哦，我们也是夏延人。他们说，不，你们不是。你们是拉科塔人。你们基本上已经变成了拉科塔人。他们意识到，实际上，他们失去了根基。他们失去了所有的遗产。他们自己的同胞并不真正认出他们。好吧，这就是悖论，不是吗？他们的游牧本性已经被
uprooted. Yeah. It's terrible what happened to them, actually. They were incredibly badly treated in this reservation in Oklahoma. They weren't given enough food. General Sheridan himself said, they've been totally lied to. We were meant to be sticking them on the reservation. Yeah. I mean, Crook spends the last years of his life speaking out against the unjust treatment that he sees as having been meted out to his adversaries on the plains. It's incredible actually when you think that the very people who fight such ruthless campaigns against them are often the most eloquent advocates of their cause. This is Sheridan, a report 1878, so less than two years after Custer's defeat. He's writing this
连根拔起。是的。他们遭遇的事情真的很可怕，实际上。他们在俄克拉荷马州的这个保留地受到了极其恶劣的对待。他们没有得到足够的食物。谢里丹将军本人说，他们被彻底欺骗了。我们本应把他们安置在保留地上。是的。我是说，克鲁克在他生命的最后几年里，一直在公开反对他所看到的对他平原上对手的不公正待遇。当你想到那些对他们进行如此无情战役的人，往往是他们事业最雄辩的倡导者时，这真的很不可思议。这是谢里丹1878年的一份报告，也就是卡斯特战败后不到两年。他写道
about the Northern Cheyenne. He says, we've occupied his country, taken away his lordly domain, destroyed his herds of game, penned him up on reservations and reduced him to poverty. For humanity's sake, let us give him enough to eat and integrity in the agent over him. So it's not that they don't know what they're doing. It's not modern wokery. No. Because the generals themselves are so conscious that promises are being broken and people are being really, really badly treated. I mean, it's also a frustration on the part of the military with the inadequacy of the civilian frameworks that have been promised and which presumably they have no control over.
关于北夏延人。他说，我们占领了他的国家，夺走了他尊贵的领地，摧毁了他的兽群，把他关在保留地里，让他陷入贫困。为了人道，让我们给他足够的食物，并让管理他的代理人保持正直。所以并不是他们不知道自己在做什么。这不是现代的“觉醒文化”（wokery）。不。因为将军们自己也非常清楚承诺正在被打破，人们正在受到非常、非常恶劣的对待。我是说，这也是军方对所承诺的民事框架不足的一种挫败感，而这些框架他们大概无法控制。
Yeah, they don't. Because as we will see later on when we get to the story of the ghost dance and Wounded Knee, those civilian frameworks are so prone to corruption. Yeah. You know, they're patronage networks basically for people to profit from. And it gives power, incredible power of life and death effectively because the person in charge of a reservation can starve his wards to death if he wants to. He can. Yeah.
是的，他们无法控制。因为正如我们稍后在讲到鬼舞和伤膝河的故事时会看到的，那些民事框架非常容易腐败。是的。你知道，它们基本上是人们从中获利的赞助网络。它赋予了生杀大权，因为负责保留地的人如果愿意，可以让他照顾的人饿死。他可以。是的。
Terrible. And that has a terrible effect on quite a lot of those agents, I think. It does indeed. So just to wrap up this bit of the story, 1877 opens, and really there are only two of the big names left out there, which are Sitting Bull and Crazy Horse. And Colonel Miles is harrying left, right, and centre. It is bearskin coat.
太可怕了。我认为这对相当多的代理人产生了可怕的影响。确实如此。所以为了结束故事的这一部分，1877年开始了，实际上外面只剩下两个大人物，那就是坐牛和疯马。迈尔斯上校正在四处骚扰。那是熊皮大衣。
He is closing in. And in January 1877, he has a showdown with Crazy Horse's band. It's called the Battle of the Wolf Mountain. Very Game of Thrones, Tom, in Montana. The heat and the dust and the sunlight of Little Big Horn are very long. I mean, it's only six months or so, but might as well be, you know, thousands of years earlier because it is 30 degrees below freezing. 30 degrees Fahrenheit, obviously.
他正在逼近。1877年1月，他与疯马的队伍进行了对决。这被称为“狼山之战”（Battle of the Wolf Mountain）。非常《权力的游戏》，汤姆，在蒙大拿州。小大角战役的热浪、尘土和阳光已经很遥远了。我是说，才过去六个月左右，但感觉就像是几千年前，因为气温在零下30度。当然是华氏零下30度。
It's blizzards. Everybody is really miserable. Crazy Horse tries to launch this attack. You know, his classic sort of maneuver, and it just doesn't work. It's too cold. There's too much snow. He hasn't got enough men. No.
那是暴风雪。每个人都非常悲惨。疯马试图发动这次攻击。你知道，他经典的机动战术，但就是行不通。太冷了。雪太多了。他没有足够的人手。不。
So actually, very few people die, but it's just awful. And they grind to a halt in the blizzard. His medicine is gone. Yeah. He's lost his mojo, basically. And he gets away, and he has a meeting with Sitting Bull. He teams up with Sitting Bull. And Sitting Bull says to him, I've had enough.
所以实际上，很少有人死亡，但这太可怕了。他们在暴风雪中停滞不前。他的“药”（medicine，指精神力量）消失了。是的。他基本上失去了魔力。他逃脱了，并与坐牛会面。他与坐牛联手。坐牛对他说，我受够了。
You know, it's only months since they beat Custer. But we haven't got any food. We're freezing. We're miserable. And it's clear the Americans are not going to give up. Yeah. And so it's too cold. So let's go to Canada.
你知道，距离他们击败卡斯特才过去几个月。但我们没有任何食物。我们快冻僵了。我们很悲惨。而且很明显，美国人不会放弃。是的。所以太冷了。所以我们去加拿大吧。
That's mad, isn't it? I mean, that's the maddest decision of all. But he says, the grandmother's land, that's what they call it, Queen Victoria's land. I'm going to the grandmother's land. You'll be better treated. He says, there's a line. And on that side of the line, you are free to do whatever you please. And that is where I'm going.
那太疯狂了，不是吗？我是说，那是所有决定中最疯狂的一个。但他说是“祖母的土地”，他们就是这样称呼维多利亚女王的土地的。我要去祖母的土地。你们会受到更好的对待。他说，有一条线。在那条线的那边，你们可以自由地做任何你们想做的事。那就是我要去的地方。
And actually, Sitting Bull is being pulled as much as anything because so many of his people, as it were, his kind of followers, have actually made the decision for him. They're already set off and they're going to Canada, off to the British Empire. Now, what's Crazy Horse going to do? Is he going to go to the British Empire as well? He sees Sitting Bull trudge off through the snows. What is Crazy Horse going to do? His people, his Aglala kind of followers are arguing among themselves
实际上，坐牛被拉走，很大程度上是因为他的许多族人，也就是他的追随者，实际上已经为他做出了决定。他们已经出发了，正前往加拿大，前往大英帝国。现在，疯马打算做什么？他也要去大英帝国吗？他看着坐牛在雪地里蹒跚而行。疯马打算做什么？他的人民，他的奥格拉拉追随者正在争论不休。
he gets quieter and quieter he's never a great man for council meetings anyway he gets quieter and quieter just sits there brooding and then on the 5th of march 1877 he and his wife pack up their teepee and they walk off into the wilderness. And what he's actually doing, he is going on a vision quest. He is going to commune with the spirits and they will tell him the way forward, what is the best path to take. Or will they? I think we should take a break at this point. And when we come back, we will find out if the Great Spirits do speak to Crazy Horse and if they do speak to him, whether the solutions they give him turn out to be effective or not. entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works.
他变得越来越安静，他本来就不是一个喜欢开会的人，他变得越来越安静，只是坐在那里沉思。然后在1877年3月5日，他和他的妻子收拾好帐篷，走进了荒野。他实际上是在进行“寻梦”（vision quest）。他要去与灵魂交流，他们会告诉他前进的方向，什么是最好的道路。或者他们会吗？我想我们应该在这一点上休息一下。当我们回来时，我们会发现伟大的灵魂是否真的对疯马说话，如果他们对他说话，他们给他的解决方案是否有效。娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐业的幕布，告诉你它是如何运作的。
We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Dominic, we left everyone on a cliffhanger. Yeah.
我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《历史的余味》。多米尼克，我们把大家留在了悬念中。是的。
Crazy Horse has gone out into the wilderness to consult with the spirits. And, you know, the big question, are they going to help him? Terrible scenes on the spirits don't help him at all. Oh, no. I know, gutting. Oh, Crazy Horse. So he goes out, he fasts, he prays, he's in the blizzards, and he's waiting for divine guidance. And no guidance comes. I mean, this is a sign actually
疯马已经走进荒野去咨询灵魂。而且，你知道，最大的问题是，他们会帮助他吗？可怕的场景，灵魂根本没有帮助他。哦，不。我知道，太令人难过了。哦，疯马。所以他出去了，他禁食，他祈祷，他在暴风雪中，他在等待神圣的指引。但没有任何指引到来。我是说，这实际上是一个迹象，
of how seriously they take it. He doesn't fabricate. He doesn't say, oh, well, actually, they told me. He doesn't make something up. Crazy horse is not a fraud. No, no, not at all. I mean, we've talked about his integrity. Yeah. This is not a man who makes things up. So he comes back and the other guys say, listen, while you were away, we've made up our minds. No good. We're giving up. There's no point. No point in fighting on.
表明他们对此有多认真。他没有捏造。他没有说，哦，好吧，实际上他们告诉了我。他没有编造什么。疯马不是骗子。不，不，一点也不。我是说，我们谈过他的正直。是的。这不是一个会编造事情的人。所以他回来了，其他人说，听着，你不在的时候，我们已经下定决心了。没用了。我们放弃了。没意义了。继续战斗没有意义。
One of them says, I got Iron Hawk, says to him, you see all the people here in rags. We all need clothing. We might as well go in. And Crozy Horse is basically a broken man. And he says, yeah, sort of whatever. And this is seen, isn't it, as marking a real turning point. So you quote Lieutenant John Burke, who watches him crazy horse ride in, having surrendered. And he says, this surrender terminates the Indian war so far as General Crook's forces are concerned. If
其中一个人说，我得到了铁鹰（Iron Hawk），对他说，你看看这里所有衣衫褴褛的人。我们都需要衣服。我们最好还是进去吧。疯马基本上是一个破碎的人。他说，是的，随它去吧。这被视为一个真正的转折点，不是吗？所以你引用了约翰·伯克中尉（Lieutenant John Burke）的话，他看着疯马骑马进来，投降了。他说，这次投降结束了印第安战争，就克鲁克将军的部队而言。如果
the government will only keep its promises and treat these red men with justice, we shall have no more Indian wars. Well, I mean, he's right to some degree. They do have no more Indian wars. But whether, of course, they're going to treat them with justice. I mean, listeners can probably guess what the answer to that's going to be. So Crazy Horse, it's the 6th of May, 1877. I mean, amazing how quick the turnaround has been.
政府能信守诺言，公正地对待这些红人，我们就不会再有印第安战争了。好吧，我是说，他在某种程度上是对的。他们确实没有再发生印第安战争。但当然，他们是否会公正地对待他们。我是说，听众可能大概能猜到答案会是什么。所以疯马，那是1877年5月6日。我是说，令人惊讶的是转变竟然如此之快。
You know, less than a year after Little Bighorn, Crazy Horse rides into fort robinson which is sort of overseeing the red cloud agency as it's called in nebraska it's this reservation in nebraska the guy who receives him is a guy called lieutenant william philo clark again he's a sign of how it's not as it were black and white the division between the you know it's not good indians and bad americans because Lieutenant Clark. He's very interested in Lakota culture, isn't he? He's really fascinated by Lakota culture. He's learned a kind of sign language that he can communicate with the Lakotas in and the scouts and the Indians in the reservation
你知道，在小大角战役后不到一年，疯马骑马进入了罗宾逊堡（Fort Robinson），它负责监督内布拉斯加州的红云机构。这是内布拉斯加州的一个保留地。接待他的人是一个叫威廉·菲洛·克拉克中尉（Lieutenant William Philo Clark）的人。这再次表明，好印第安人和坏美国人之间的划分并不是非黑即白的，因为克拉克中尉。他对拉科塔文化非常感兴趣，不是吗？他真的对拉科塔文化很着迷。他学会了一种手语，可以用它与拉科塔人交流，而保留地里的侦察兵和印第安人
think of Lieutenant Clark as a good chap, who looks out for them and does his best for them. And they smoke a peace pipe together, and Crazy Horse gives this guy... We talked about handshaking as a theme of the series, Tom. He gives him his left hand, and that symbolizes a desire for peace. So he holds out his hand. The tragedy is that Crazy Horse has been sold a complete lie. He had said, we would come in if you would give us our own agency, our own reservation west of the Black Hills, and if we will be allowed to go on a buffalo hunt. And there's tremendous kind of pathos there, isn't there? Yeah. Because he clearly doesn't realise the scale of the catastrophe that
认为克拉克中尉是一个好人，他照顾他们并为他们尽力。他们一起抽了和平烟斗，疯马给了这个人……汤姆，我们谈过握手作为本系列的主题。他伸出了左手，这象征着对和平的渴望。所以他伸出了手。悲剧在于疯马被彻底欺骗了。他曾说，如果你们给我们自己的机构，我们在黑山西部自己的保留地，并且如果我们被允许去猎野牛，我们就会进来。这其中有一种巨大的悲怆，不是吗？是的。因为他显然没有意识到野牛所遭受的灾难规模。
has overwhelmed the buffalo. The bison, yeah. And General Crook says, sure, I'll just check with the great father in Washington, DC, the president. But he knows there is no possibility whatsoever that Crazy Horse will get either of those things. And actually, they won't. The government have no intention of letting him go hunting. Hunting is dead.
野牛，是的。克鲁克将军说，当然，我会去和华盛顿特区的伟大父亲，也就是总统核实一下。但他知道疯马根本不可能得到这两样东西中的任何一样。实际上，他们也不会得到。政府根本没打算让他去打猎。打猎已经死了。
They must become farmers now. So the weeks go by and Crazy Horse becomes very, very miserable and restive. And the army say to him, listen, why don't you go to Washington, if you like, to the new president, Rutherford B. Hayes. Why don't you go and meet Rutherford B. Hayes? That'd be nice for you. And he says, no. And I think that is, you know, he doesn't go there. He doesn't put on the top hat.
他们现在必须成为农民。所以几周过去了，疯马变得非常、非常悲惨和不安。军队对他说，听着，如果你愿意，为什么不去华盛顿见见新总统拉瑟福德·B·海斯（Rutherford B. Hayes）呢？为什么不去见见拉瑟福德·B·海斯？这对你来说会很好。他说，不。我认为那是，你知道，他没有去那里。他没有戴上高礼帽。
He doesn't get photographed. Yeah. You admire him for that, Tom. I do admire him. I'd like to meet Rutherford B. Hayes. Crazy name, crazy guy. Yeah, I know you would, of course, but you are not a wild spirit galloping around the plains killing buffalo. It's true. Never pretended to be, Tom. That is the difference between you and Crazy Horse, Dominic. Yeah, one of many, actually.
他从不拍照。是的。汤姆，你很钦佩他这一点。我确实很钦佩他。我想见见拉瑟福德·B·海斯。名字很疯狂，人也很疯狂。是的，我知道你当然想见，但你并不是那种在平原上驰骋、猎杀野牛的狂野灵魂。确实如此。汤姆，我从来没假装过是那样的人。多米尼克，这就是你和疯马的区别。是的，实际上这只是众多区别之一。
Let's be honest. I'm just promoting the most salient point of difference. The army feel quite sorry for him. So Lieutenant William Philo Clark reports, he says Crazy Horse wants to do the right thing. He just doesn't know what the right thing is. Another captain says Crazy Horse is all right. If people would just leave him alone and not buzz him so much, he'd come out all right. In other words, because he's well-known, he's sort of being bullied
老实说，我只是在强调最显著的区别点。军队对他感到相当同情。威廉·菲洛·克拉克中尉报告说，疯马想做正确的事。他只是不知道什么是正确的事。另一位上尉说疯马没问题。如果人们能让他一个人待着，别那么烦他，他会好起来的。换句话说，因为他很有名，他有点被欺负了。
and people are making fun of him and giving him a tough time and stuff. I mean, they'd be taking selfies of him, wouldn't they? Well, worse than that, I think yeah we talked very early on 6 000 podcasts ago about how the so-called indians the native americans were never united and even within these groups they're not united there are people out to get him you know there are people who say oh he's made a name for himself he thinks he's you know billy big boots let's bring him down i'd like to be the big man now instead of Crazy Horse so there are people whispering against him
人们在取笑他，让他日子不好过之类的。我的意思是，他们会拿着手机跟他自拍，对吧？嗯，比那更糟，我想是的。我们在6000集播客之前很早就谈到过，所谓的印第安人，即美洲原住民，从来没有团结过，即使在这些群体内部，他们也不团结。有人想对付他，你知道，有人说“哦，他给自己闯出了名堂，他以为自己了不起，让我们把他拉下马吧，我现在想当大人物，而不是疯马”，所以有人在背后议论他。
and saying oh he's plotting against Red Cloud all of this kind of thing so he's sort of being ostracised a little bit and he's conscious
说他在密谋反对红云，诸如此类的事情，所以他有点被排挤了，而且他意识到
that he's being plotted against so actually what he spends his time doing it's a very sad time I know you love Crazy Horse and you also love you love birds don't you
有人在密谋对付他，所以他实际上把时间都花在这些事情上，这是一段非常悲伤的时光。我知道你喜欢疯马，你也喜欢鸟，不是吗？
so this is a very sad moment for you. This terrible story where he rides out, doesn't he? Yeah. And he sees a dead eagle. Yeah. Lying in the plains. And he says, I saw myself.
所以这对你来说是一个非常悲伤的时刻。这个可怕的故事，他骑马出去了，对吧？是的。他看到了一只死鹰。是的。躺在平原上。他说，我看到了我自己。
Yeah. There's that. And he has a dream about riding a white pony. And he rides this pony and there's enemies on every side of him. And he dies in the dream, but not of a bullet. And he wakes up and he tells everybody, he says, I died, but I wasn't shot. But, you know, he thinks something is coming.
是的。就是那样。他做了一个关于骑白马的梦。他骑着这匹马，周围都是敌人。他在梦中死了，但不是死于子弹。他醒来后告诉大家，他说，我死了，但我没有被枪杀。但是，你知道，他觉得有什么事情要发生了。
So to that extent, he still has good medicine. Yeah. As we'll see. As we will see, yeah. So it's against this background. Remember we said that General Crook in particular is very canny and he is recruiting groups to play off against other groups, recruiting them into the army and so on
所以在某种程度上，他仍然有很好的“药”（精神力量）。是的。正如我们将要看到的。正如我们将要看到的，是的。所以是在这样的背景下。还记得我们说过克鲁克将军特别精明，他正在招募一些部落去对抗另一些部落，把他们招募进军队等等。
effectively. And he says, I would like Crazy Horse to come and help me in a campaign. There's another tribe called the, I always find it a strange name, I assume it's Nez Perce, Pierce Noses. But it's always written without the accent
实际上是这样。他说，我希望疯马能来帮我参加一场战役。还有另一个部落叫，我总觉得这个名字很奇怪，我假设是内兹珀斯人（Nez Perce），“刺鼻人”。但它总是写成没有重音符号的样子。
so it looks like somebody called Nez Perce. Let's just say a Native American people. Brilliant. With a Frenchified name. Exactly. These Frenchified fops. They're all eating garlic and stripy T-shirts, onions. Right.
所以看起来像是一个叫内兹珀斯的人。我们就说是一个美洲原住民部落吧。太棒了。带着一个法语化的名字。没错。这些法语化的花花公子。他们都在吃大蒜，穿着条纹T恤，吃洋葱。对。
So Lieutenant Philo Clark says, are you going to come with us and fight these fellows? And they have this meeting, and Crazy Horse at first says, I thought you told me the fighting was over. Really? I mean, I was only fighting you quite recently and now you want to drag me out again. They say, oh yeah, definitely. And he says, fine. Yes. Yes. I'll come with you. But now there's a terrible error, mistranslation crazy horse is the only person i think i mean there can't be many people in history whose entire fate is decided by a bad interpreter but this is what happens now because listeners will remember a man called frank gruard
所以菲洛·克拉克中尉说，你要跟我们一起去打这些人吗？他们开了个会，疯马起初说，我以为你告诉我战斗已经结束了。真的吗？我的意思是，我最近才刚和你打过仗，现在你又想把我拖出去。他们说，哦，是的，绝对是。他说，好吧。是的。是的。我会跟你去。但现在出了一个可怕的错误，翻译错误。疯马是唯一一个，我想，我的意思是历史上不可能有很多人整个命运都被一个糟糕的翻译所决定，但现在发生的就是这种情况，因为听众会记得一个叫弗兰克·格鲁阿德的人。
flashman son son of flashman and a south sea islander polynesian yeah frank gruard is still in business and is interpreting and he translates crazy horse's words crazy horse had actually said we'll come north of you and fight until all these french fellows are killed the nez per se frank gruard translates this as yeah i intend to go north and fight until every white man is killed. So you say it's a mistranslation. Yeah. But I reckon, I mean, Gruard is full of shit. Right.
弗莱什曼的儿子，弗莱什曼的儿子，一个南太平洋岛民，波利尼西亚人。是的，弗兰克·格鲁阿德还在干这一行，他在做翻译，他翻译了疯马的话。疯马实际上说的是“我们会来到你们北边，战斗直到所有这些法国佬（内兹珀斯人）被杀光”。弗兰克·格鲁阿德把它翻译成“是的，我打算去北边战斗，直到每一个白人都被杀光”。所以你说这是一个翻译错误。是的。但我认为，我的意思是，格鲁阿德满嘴胡言。对。
He's a crock of shit, I'd go so far as to say. Yeah, technical term is that, Tom. So he clearly is spreading rubbish stories about Crazy Horse, because he has some story that he owned a piece of buckskin that he'd got from Crazy Horse's father. And that on this piece of buckskin, the entire 800 year history of the Lakota had been written. And also that he had some enormous cloak made up of sitting bull scalp victims. Yeah. And that both of these had been burned down in a fire.
他简直是一堆垃圾，我甚至可以这么说。是的，汤姆，这是专业术语。所以他显然在散布关于疯马的垃圾故事，因为他有个故事说他拥有一块从疯马父亲那里得到的鹿皮。在这块鹿皮上，写着拉科塔人800年的全部历史。还有他有一件巨大的斗篷，是用坐牛剥下的受害者头皮做的。是的。而且这两样东西都在一场火灾中被烧毁了。
So I... You mistrust his motives. I do not think he's the most trustworthy person. I think you're judging him by flashman though, aren't you? You're judging him by his father's standards. No, I'm not. Because I mean, genuinely, the scope for George MacDonald Fraser to say that he's Flashman's son is because he tells all kinds
所以我……你怀疑他的动机。我不认为他是一个最值得信任的人。我想你是用弗莱什曼的标准来评判他，对吧？你是用他父亲的标准来评判他。不，我没有。因为我的意思是，乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽说他是弗莱什曼的儿子，是因为他讲了各种各样。
of nonsense stories about his parentage. I mean, almost everything he says is made up. Yes. So it is possible, and some historians do think that this is a trick, that he's betrayed Crazy Horse. Because he says to Lieutenant Clark, Crazy Horse says he's going to kill every white man in the North or whatever.
关于他身世的无稽之谈。我的意思是，他说的几乎每一件事都是编造的。是的。所以这是可能的，一些历史学家确实认为这是一个诡计，他背叛了疯马。因为他告诉克拉克中尉，疯马说他要杀光北方的每一个白人，或者诸如此类的话。
Yeah. I think he's got blood on his hands. Clark is like, what? And he loses his temper with Crazy Horse. Crazy Horse loses his temper with him and storms out of the meeting. So what a crazy end to this meeting. Actually, Crazy Horse was agreeing he was going to go. Anyway, immediately the American military and whatnot start saying,
是的。我觉得他手上沾满了鲜血。克拉克心想，什么？他向疯马发火了。疯马也向他发火，冲出了会议室。所以这次会议的结局真是太疯狂了。实际上，疯马当时是同意他会去的。无论如何，美国军方和其他人立即开始说，
oh my God, Crazy Horse has gone mad. He's going to attack us all. He's going to break out. I mean, it's interesting, isn't it? The degree to which for Americans, the fact he's called Crazy Horse leads them to think that he is crazy. Yeah. They think he is crazy, I think, at this point. They think he's just gone mad. So General Crook arrives at the reservation. Oh, gosh, what's going to happen? Sheridan has told him, like, you have to sort this out. We can't allow Crazy Horse to break out and start roaming around in a sort of mad manner.
哦，天哪，疯马疯了。他要攻击我们所有人。他要逃跑了。我的意思是，这很有趣，不是吗？对于美国人来说，他叫“疯马”这一事实导致他们认为他真的疯了。是的。我认为此时他们认为他疯了。他们认为他只是疯了。所以克鲁克将军到达了保留地。哦，天哪，会发生什么？谢里丹告诉他，你必须解决这个问题。我们不能允许疯马逃跑，开始以一种疯狂的方式四处游荡。
Crook goes to the reservation. He meets with Red Cloud, you know, the old kind of, as it were, the grey beard. The Obi-Wan. The Obi-Wan. Now, Red Cloud hates Crazy Horse because he thinks Crazy Horse is a rival of his. He says to Crook, let's just kill him. Let's kill him now.
克鲁克去了保留地。他会见了红云，你知道，那个老一辈的，可以说是“灰胡子”。那个欧比旺。那个欧比旺。现在，红云讨厌疯马，因为他认为疯马是他的竞争对手。他对克鲁克说，我们杀了他吧。我们现在就杀了他。
Crook said, whoa, that's kind of a bit much. Steady on. Yeah, exactly. Steady on. We're not like that. He says, we'll arrest him. We'll arrest him tomorrow. Actually, what Crazy Horse then does on the 4th of September, he flees.
克鲁克说，哇，这有点过分了。冷静点。是的，没错。冷静点。我们不是那样的人。他说，我们会逮捕他。我们明天就逮捕他。实际上，疯马在9月4日所做的是，他逃跑了。
He flees from Fort Robinson and he goes off to the Spotted Tail Agency and he goes to a place called Camp Sheridan. So he's gone on the run, effectively. At Camp Sheridan, his uncle, Spotted Tail, is in situ. Another of the great bigwigs, like Red Cloud. Crazy Horse arrives, and he says, uncle, you know, I'm in a terrible mess. Please will you give me a home here at this agency? And there's hundreds of people there because crazy horse is such a big no you know such a big figure so well known and spotted tail humiliates him in front of all these people he says uh you know no basically nephew he says we never have any trouble at this agency i am the chief if you you know you would have to listen to me you can't be coming here causing trouble and all this kind of thing
他从罗宾逊堡逃走，去了斑点尾巴代理处，去了叫谢里丹营的地方。所以他实际上是在逃亡。在谢里丹营，他的叔叔斑点尾巴在那里。另一位大人物，就像红云一样。疯马到了，他说，叔叔，你知道，我陷入了可怕的困境。请你给我一个家，在这个代理处好吗？那里有数百人，因为疯马是一个如此重要的人物，如此出名，而斑点尾巴在所有人面前羞辱了他。他说，呃，你知道，不，基本上，侄子，他说，我们在这个代理处从来没有任何麻烦，我是首领，如果你，你知道，你必须听我的，你不能来这里制造麻烦，诸如此类的事情。
and crazy horse is described as why he like physically wilts well there's this incredible description by lieutenant jesse lee yes who's one of the officers in charge of the reservation and describes crazy horse seeming like a frightened trembling wild animal brought to bay hoping for confidence one moment and fearing treachery the next oh it's terrible so they Crazy Horse, the officers, they don't come out of this too badly. They say, look, come here, come on, come into the hut or whatever. And we'll have a little chat, see if we can sort this out. And he goes in and it's a pitiful scene, isn't it? He says to them, I don't want any trouble. I want to get away from the trouble at Red Cloud. They've misunderstood and misinterpreted me there.
疯马被描述为他身体上萎靡了。是的，杰西·李中尉有这种令人难以置信的描述，他是负责保留地的军官之一，他描述疯马看起来像一只被逼入绝境、受惊颤抖的野生动物，一会儿希望得到信任，一会儿又害怕背叛。哦，太可怕了。所以他们，疯马，军官们，他们表现得还不算太差。他们说，看，来这里，来吧，进小屋或者什么地方。我们会聊聊，看看能不能解决这个问题。他进去了，那是一个悲惨的场景，不是吗？他对他们说，我不想惹任何麻烦。我想远离红云那里的麻烦。他们在那里误解并曲解了我。
I would like to be transferred to this agency they gave me no rest at red cloud i was talked to night and day my brain is in a whirl i just want to do what is right it's actually so sad it's like a sort of school boy summoned to see the headmaster who doesn't understand what he's done wrong but knows he's in the most terrible trouble i mean that's basically where crazy horse is and so he says he will go and plead his cause, plead his case. Yeah. Go back to Fort Robinson and explain himself and what has gone wrong. One of the things he does that I think, again, I kind of admire him for is that before he leaves, he makes sure that his wife is okay. She's secure and safe. And that's Blackshaw, who will,
我想被转移到这个代理处，他们在红云那里没让我休息，我日夜被谈话，我的大脑一片混乱，我只想做正确的事。这真的很悲伤，就像一个被叫去见校长的学生，他不知道自己做错了什么，但知道自己陷入了最可怕的麻烦。我的意思是，这基本上就是疯马的处境，所以他说他会去为自己辩护，陈述他的情况。是的。回到罗宾逊堡解释自己，以及到底出了什么问题。他做的一件事，我认为，再次，我有点钦佩他，那就是在他离开之前，他确保他的妻子没事。她是安全可靠的。那是黑肖，她会，
I think she dies of the spanish flu oh really he lives for a long time we're now at the point in the story where some of these people that we're talking about are going to be alive in the second world war i know you know they have this homeric quality we've been saying it and it seems astonishing that they live to see i know the spanish flu and the second world War. Yeah, exactly. So the next day, Crazy Horse goes back to Fort Robinson and actually Lieutenant Lee, who you quoted, he goes with him to sort of escort him. They get to Fort Robinson and Lieutenant Lee thinks,
我想她死于西班牙流感，哦，真的吗？他活了很长时间，我们现在处于故事的这一点，我们谈论的一些人将在第二次世界大战中还活着。我知道，你知道，他们有一种荷马史诗般的品质，我们一直在说，他们能活到看到，我知道，西班牙流感和第二次世界大战，这令人震惊。是的，没错。所以第二天，疯马回到罗宾逊堡，实际上你引用的李中尉，他和他一起去，算是护送他。他们到达罗宾逊堡，李中尉心想，
oh, this doesn't feel right. The place is rammed with Red Clouds warriors and some of them have actually in war paint and there are loads of cavalrymen with rifles and it all feels a little bit intimidating so when they get there the officer of the day who is a guy called captain kennington he says you know you're not going to get to talk to the colonel today i'll take charge of you you know okay fine thank you very much i'll take you now and lieutenant lee is a bit disturbed about this. Like, why is he not going to get to talk to the Colonel? And he goes to see the Colonel himself, Lieutenant Lee. He
哦，这感觉不对。这个地方挤满了红云的战士，他们中的一些人实际上涂着战漆，还有大量的骑兵带着步枪，这一切感觉有点吓人。所以当他们到达那里时，当天的值班军官，一个叫肯宁顿上尉的人，他说，你知道，你今天见不到上校了，我来负责你，你知道，好吧，没问题，非常感谢，我现在带你走。李中尉对此感到有点不安。就像，为什么他见不到上校？他自己去见上校了，李中尉。他
says, crazy horse, you wait here. I'll go and see the Colonel. He goes to see the Colonel. It's called Colonel Bradley. He says, crazy horse wants to come and talk to you and explain himself. Colonel Bradley just says, look, I'm really sorry. It's too late. The orders have come from General Sheridan. They've had enough of Crazy Horse. We're going to take him right now to HQ in Chicago, and then we're going to put him on a train or something, and we're going to take him to an island off the coast of Florida, and he'll just be left there to rot, one of the Tortugas. Which for Crazy Horse would be the worst fate imaginable.
说，疯马，你在这里等。我去见上校。他去见上校。那个人叫布拉德利上校。他说，疯马想来和你谈谈，解释一下自己。布拉德利上校只是说，看，我真的很抱歉。太晚了。命令已经从谢里丹将军那里下来了。他们受够了疯马。我们现在就要把他带到芝加哥的总部，然后我们要把他送上火车什么的，我们要把他带到佛罗里达海岸外的一个岛上，他就会被留在那里腐烂，托尔图加斯群岛之一。这对疯马来说将是能想象到的最糟糕的命运。
It would be. It'd be terrible you know they're all quite sad about it but like well the decision has been made what can we do so if tenant lee goes back to crazy horse and he says you know it's night it's very late so you can't see the colonel i think you should just go with them you know you won't be harmed you know he just tries to calm him and crazy horse is sort of smiling weakly fine and two guys take crazy horse they take him outside and one of them is little big man isn't it yeah his friend his cousin i mean they were relatives yeah and little big man had fought at the bighorn yeah but here he is he's decided which side he's on do you know what i mean i know we've said it so many times it is like something from a greek tragedy
确实会是。那会很可怕，你知道他们对此都感到很悲伤，但就像，好吧，决定已经做出了，我们能做什么呢？所以李中尉回到疯马身边，他说，你知道，现在是晚上，很晚了，所以你见不到上校，我想你应该就跟他们走，你知道，你不会受到伤害的，你知道，他只是试图让他冷静下来，疯马有点虚弱地笑着，好吧。两个人带走了疯马，他们把他带到外面，其中一个是“小大个子”，不是吗？是的，他的朋友，他的堂兄，我的意思是他们是亲戚。是的，小大个子在小大角战役中战斗过。是的，但在这里，他决定了他站在哪一边。你知道我的意思吗？我知道我们已经说过很多次了，这就像希腊悲剧里的东西。
isn't it it really is is. So here is betrayal. It's betrayal. Yeah, they take him outside and then Crazy Horse is like, what? They seem to be turning towards the guardhouse and there's a cell. And he can see inside and he can see that there's this big cell and there's these blokes who are shackled to iron balls. And that is the worst thing imaginable for someone who is used to riding around the plains without being penned in a reservation,
不是吗？确实是。所以这就是背叛。这是背叛。是的，他们把他带到外面，然后疯马心想，什么？他们似乎正转向警卫室，那里有一个牢房。他能看到里面，他能看到有一个大牢房，里面有那些被锁在铁球上的家伙。对于一个习惯于在平原上骑马而不被关在保留地里的人来说，这是能想象到的最糟糕的事情，
let alone in a cell. Exactly. And he says, I don't want to go in there. That's the place where they keep the prisoners. And at that moment, he tries to break free. And he tries to break free from Little Big Man and Captain Kennington, who are holding his two wrists. And Little Big Man goes to grab him again.
更不用说在牢房里了。没错。他说，我不想进去。那是他们关押囚犯的地方。就在那一刻，他试图挣脱。他试图从抓住他两个手腕的小大个子和肯宁顿上尉手中挣脱。小大个子又去抓他。
And Crazy Horse has got a hidden knife he pulls out the knife and he slashes little big man's arm and at that point captain canes and shouts stab the son of a bitch stab the son of a bitch and a private comes up behind him and thrusts his bayonet into crazy horse's back and so his vision was right he wasn't shot shot. He wasn't shot. He pierces his kidney in his lung. Crazy Horse screams and falls to the ground and the guy stabs him again. And in the confusion and the melee, the surgeon of the post,
疯马有一把藏起来的刀，他拔出刀，划伤了小大个子的手臂，就在那时，肯宁顿上尉大喊“刺死这个狗娘养的，刺死这个狗娘养的”，一个列兵从他身后走过来，把刺刀刺进了疯马的背部，所以他的预感是对的，他没有被枪杀。他没有被枪杀。他刺穿了他的肾脏和肺。疯马尖叫着倒在地上，那个人又刺了他一下。在混乱和混战中，驻地的外科医生，
who is a man with the implausible name of Valentine T. McGillicuddy, he pushes his way through and he sees that Crazy Horse is obviously in a terrible state. There's blood everywhere. They carry him into an office. And Dominic, crucially, they do not lay him on a cot. No, he asked to be put on the floor. Crazy Horse refuses to lie on the cot.
一个名字叫瓦伦丁·T·麦吉利卡迪的家伙，他挤了进来，他看到疯马显然处于一种可怕的状态。到处都是血。他们把他抬进了一间办公室。多米尼克，关键的是，他们没有把他放在行军床上。不，他要求被放在地板上。疯马拒绝躺在行军床上。
Yes. What's he got against lying on a cot? We'll come to that in a minute. Okay. Oh, I'm excited. I want to know. I can't wait. And actually it's terrible. He lingers for hours and he just keeps saying, I don't know why they stabbed me. But he says, interestingly, the white men are not to blame for this. It's the Indians who are to blame. I've been betrayed by my own people. And actually, Crazy Horse's father always said there was Red Cloud and Spotted Tail, the bigwigs who had plotted against his son. The top-hatted Washington.
是的。他躺在行军床上有什么问题吗？我们一会儿再说。好的。哦，我很兴奋。我想知道。我等不及了。而且这真的很可怕。他徘徊了几个小时，他只是不停地说，我不知道他们为什么要刺我。但他有趣地说，白人对此不应受到指责。是印第安人应该受到指责。我被我的人民背叛了。实际上，疯马的父亲总是说，是红云和斑点尾巴，那些密谋反对他儿子的大人物。华盛顿的高礼帽。
Yes, exactly. And he died just before midnight, didn't he? In his last words, Tom, I just want to be left alone. All I wanted was to be left alone. So sad. So Dominic, you may remember there was a reading about Custer from Ian Frazier's book, On the Great Plains, which I said I adored and I carried around with me when I was visiting all these sites. And I love that book because it gets something that is charismatic about Custer, but it also completely gets what is charismatic about Crazy Horse.
是的，没错。他在午夜前去世了，不是吗？汤姆，他最后的遗言是，我只想一个人待着。我想要的只是一个人待着。太悲伤了。所以多米尼克，你可能记得伊恩·弗雷泽的书《在大平原上》中有一段关于卡斯特的阅读，我说过我很崇拜它，我在访问所有这些遗址时都随身带着它。我喜欢那本书，因为它捕捉到了卡斯特身上那种有魅力的地方，但也完全捕捉到了疯马身上那种有魅力的地方。
And he talks about how there are scholars who look at the cult of Crazy Horse and say it's mad. You know, he was nobody. And he says, no, I love Crazy Horse. I admire him. And then he writes this passage about his death. What I return to most often when I think of Crazy Horse is the fact that in the adjutant's office he refused to lie on the cot. Mortally wounded, frothing at the mouth, grinding his teeth in pain, he chose the floor instead. What a distance is between that cot and floor. On the cot he would have been, in some sense, ours, an object of pity, an accident victim, the noble red man, the last of his race, etc, etc. But on the floor, Crazy Horse was Crazy Horse still. On the floor, he remembered Agent Lee, summoned him, forgave him. On the floor, unable to rise, he was guarded by soldiers even then. On the floor, he said goodbye to his father. And on the floor, still as far from white men as the limitless continent they once dreamed of, he died. Touched the clouds, pulled the blanket over his face. That is the lodge of Crazy Horse. Lying where he chose, Crazy Horse showed the rest of us
他谈到有一些学者研究疯马崇拜，说那是疯狂的。你知道，他什么都不是。他说，不，我爱疯马。我钦佩他。然后他写了这段关于他死亡的段落。当我想到疯马时，我最常回想起的是，在副官办公室里，他拒绝躺在行军床上。身受致命伤，口吐白沫，痛苦地咬着牙，他选择了地板。那张行军床和地板之间的距离有多大。在行军床上，他在某种意义上会是我们的，一个怜悯的对象，一个事故受害者，高贵的红人，他种族的最后一人，等等等等。但在地板上，疯马依然是疯马。在地板上，他想起了李代理人，召见了他，原谅了他。在地板上，无法起身，即使在那时他也被士兵守卫着。在地板上，他向父亲告别。在地板上，依然远离白人，就像他们曾经梦想的无限大陆一样，他死了。触碰了云朵，把毯子拉过脸。那就是疯马的帐篷。躺在他选择的地方，疯马向我们其他人展示了
where we are standing. With his body, he demonstrated that the floor of an army office was part of the land and that the land was still his. I mean, it's tremendous, soaring prose. And you can imagine the impact of that when you're out in the plains and feeling very romantic and sad about the whole business. Yeah, it is a great piece of writing. And it's a sad story.
我们站在哪里。用他的身体，他证明了军队办公室的地板是土地的一部分，而那片土地依然是他的。我的意思是，这是了不起的、高昂的散文。当你身处平原，对整个事情感到非常浪漫和悲伤时，你可以想象那种影响。是的，这是一篇伟大的文章。这是一个悲伤的故事。
You know, a great warrior deserved a better end. I think it's fair to say, Tom. But I think it has the quality of Arthur going off to Avalon. He has a dignity in death that none of the other heroes of The Little Bighorn, so Sitting Bull and Gaul, most notably, will have, as we will see. Yeah. Before we conclude the episode, let's just say what happened to Sitting Bull,
你知道，一位伟大的战士值得一个更好的结局。我认为公平地说，汤姆。但我认为它有一种亚瑟王前往阿瓦隆的品质。他在死亡中有一种尊严，这是小大角战役的其他英雄，最著名的是坐牛和高尔，所没有的，正如我们将要看到的。是的。在结束本集之前，让我们说说坐牛发生了什么，
because he had, of course, gone off to Canada. And actually, Canada comes out of this quite well, doesn't it, Tom? Hurrah for Canada. It does, yeah. We get a lot of grief from Canadians, not enough Canadian history. I think this series can count as 26 episodes of Canadian history. Yeah. Well, so it's a point that Bentin had made long before when there was a big kind of argument about whether Custer should keep his word or not. And he says,
因为他当然去了加拿大。实际上，加拿大在这件事上表现得相当不错，不是吗，汤姆？为加拿大欢呼。确实，是的。我们从加拿大人那里得到了很多抱怨，没有足够的加拿大历史。我认为这个系列可以算作26集的加拿大历史。是的。好吧，所以这是本廷很久以前提出的一个观点，当时关于卡斯特是否应该信守诺言有一个很大的争论。他说，
we should, because that's what they do in Canada and they don't have trouble in Canada. Bentin, always right. That keeping your word is really, really important. Well, actually, Sitting Bull said that, didn't he? He got on really well with the Mounties. He thought the Mounties were great. He loved their red coats. And I think there's a lesson there for all American listeners. Red coats, good.
我们应该，因为这就是他们在加拿大所做的，而且他们在加拿大没有麻烦。本廷，总是对的。信守诺言真的非常非常重要。好吧，实际上，坐牛是这么说的，不是吗？他和骑警相处得非常好。他认为骑警很棒。他喜欢他们的红外套。我想这对所有美国听众来说都是一个教训。红外套，好。
Yes. I mean, Sitting Bull says of the United States, that country is poisoned with blood, contrasting it with Canada. Cranky. Not the grandmother's land though. The grandmother's land was brilliant. So he went to canada and um you know at first all was good meanwhile of course back in america while he's been gone so when he's away he becomes this great legend because he's somebody who's he's the one who escaped so people tell all these mad stories
是的。我的意思是，坐牛谈到美国时说，那个国家被鲜血毒害了，这与加拿大形成了对比。古怪。但不是祖母的土地。祖母的土地很棒。所以他去了加拿大，嗯，你知道，起初一切都很好，与此同时，当然，在美国，当他离开的时候，所以当他不在的时候，他成为了这个伟大的传奇，因为他是那个逃脱的人，所以人们讲述所有这些疯狂的故事
about him one person captain mcarry, I think his name was, published a book or something saying that Sitting Bull could read French and had studied the campaigns of Napoleon. Was that with the nez per se? Yeah, undoubtedly. Another man, another expert, said that Sitting Bull was actually not a Lakota. He was a very hushute white man called Bison McLean.
关于他，一个人，麦卡里上尉，我想是这个名字，出版了一本书什么的，说坐牛能读法语，研究过拿破仑的战役。那是和内兹珀斯人一起吗？是的，毫无疑问。另一个人，另一位专家，说坐牛实际上不是拉科塔人。他是一个非常安静的白人，叫比森·麦克莱恩。
Of course he was. Who had graduated from West Point in 1848 and had subsequently been court-martialed and then had joined the Lakota. That's an intriguing story. Anyway, he wasn't either of those things. He's actually just up in Canada. And do you know what?
当然他是。他于1848年从西点军校毕业，随后被军事法庭审判，然后加入了拉科塔人。这是一个引人入胜的故事。无论如何，他都不是那些东西。他实际上只是在加拿大。你知道吗？
As much as he likes Canada... Canadians don't want him really, do they? They're just not that into him. No, the buffalo are kind of becoming extinct there as well. He's, of course, not Canadian. So the Canadians don't really want to help him. He and his followers sometimes go close to the border or go over the border. And that creates issues for the Canadians because it's kind of a border crisis with the Americans. And over time, they start to run out of food again. So the years pass by 1879, 1880. And they're being menaced by the native peoples in Canada as well, aren't they? Oh yeah, the native peoples there despise him.
尽管他喜欢加拿大……加拿大人其实并不想要他，对吧？他们对他没那么感兴趣。不，那里的野牛也快灭绝了。他当然不是加拿大人。所以加拿大人并不真的想帮他。他和他的追随者有时靠近边境或越过边境。这给加拿大人带来了问题，因为这算是一种与美国人的边境危机。随着时间的推移，他们的食物又开始短缺了。所以岁月流逝，1879年，1880年。他们也受到加拿大原住民的威胁，不是吗？哦，是的，那里的原住民鄙视他。
They don't want anything to do with him at all because they're competing for the same resources. Yeah, which are depleted. Exactly. So to quote one of the many books on this subject, by early 1881, only the weak and the elderly stood by sitting bulls, subsisting on fish, small game, and hand out some friendly traders.
他们根本不想和他有任何关系，因为他们在争夺相同的资源。是的，这些资源已经枯竭了。没错。所以引用关于这个主题的众多书籍中的一本，到1881年初，只有弱者和老人站在坐牛身边，靠鱼、小猎物和友好商人的施舍维持生活。
Clothing rotted and fell from their bodies. War parties of Canadian Indians circled their tattered village like vultures so a very kind of pathetic end and eventually he just decides i'm going to go back to america and surrender and he does that in july 1881 he cuts a very very forlorn and miserable figure all the officers say he doesn't seem well. He seems very depressed, hungry, miserable. Well, he sings a sad song, doesn't he? A warrior I have been now, it is all over, a hard time I have. Thank God it was short, eh? Well, you can imagine that to
衣服腐烂并从他们身上脱落。加拿大印第安人的战队像秃鹫一样盘旋在他们破烂的村庄周围，所以这是一个非常可怜的结局，最终他只是决定我要回到美国投降，他在1881年7月这样做了。他看起来非常非常凄凉和悲惨，所有的军官都说他看起来不太好。他看起来非常沮丧、饥饿、悲惨。好吧，他唱了一首悲伤的歌，不是吗？我曾经是一名战士，现在，一切都结束了，我度过了一段艰难的时光。谢天谢地，它很短，对吧？好吧，你可以想象那对
sacred spirit. Yes. So he surrenders his rifle, Winchester rifle. He gives it to one of his sons to give it to the americans and he says i surrender this rifle to you through my young son who i now desire to teach in this manner that he becomes a friend of the americans i want him to learn the habits of the whites and to be educated as their sons are educated this boy has given it to you and he now wants to know how he is going to make a living because the truth is sitting will doesn't really want his son to learn the ways of the americans and even if he did they're not going to teach him how to make a living they're just going to say turn yourself into a farmer by your own efforts or become an alcoholic right so actually yet again he has lied to he is told you're going to go to the standing rock agency. You'll be treated like any other Indians. That doesn't happen at all. They put him on a steamboat. On the General
神圣的精神。是的。所以他交出了他的步枪，温彻斯特步枪。他把它交给他的一个儿子，让他交给美国人，他说，我通过我年轻的儿子把这支步枪交给你，我现在的愿望是教导他，以这种方式，让他成为美国人的朋友，我希望他学习白人的习惯，像他们的儿子一样受教育。这个男孩把它交给了你，他现在想知道他将如何谋生，因为事实是，坐牛并不真的希望他的儿子学习美国人的方式，即使他想，他们也不会教他如何谋生，他们只会说，通过你自己的努力把自己变成一个农民，或者变成一个酒鬼，对吧？所以实际上，他又一次被骗了，他被告知你要去立岩代理处。你会像其他印第安人一样被对待。那根本没有发生。他们把他送上一艘汽船。在“谢尔曼将军号”上，不是吗？在伤口上撒盐。是的，“谢尔曼将军号”汽船。他们把他带到350英里以南的兰德尔堡。他是一名战俘。在那里，他只是腐烂。正是在那里，有一些著名的象形文字，基本上是坐牛画的插图，因为他得到了一些蜡笔和纸。他总是画同样的东西，战斗和伟大战斗的图片，所有这些事情，还有猎野牛。你知道吗？我的意思是，他们输了，但他们赢得了那场伟大的战斗。有一个惊人的统计数据，估计在美洲陆军进行的整个印第安战争期间，政府花费了大约一百万美元来杀死每一个印第安人。
Sherman, isn't it? To rub salt in the wound. Yeah, the General Sherman steamboat. And they take him off to Fort Randall, 350 miles further south. And he's a prisoner of war. And there, he just rots. It's there that there are some famous pictograms, basically illustrations drawn by Sitting Bull because he was given sort of crayons and pieces of paper. And he always drew the same thing, pictures of battles and great fights and all this sort of thing and buffalo hunts. And do you know what? I mean, they lose, but they had won that great battle. And there's an amazing statistic that the estimate is that during the entirety of the Indian Wars fought by the United States Army, the government spent about a million dollars to kill each Indian.
哇。我的意思是，那是一场非常非常昂贵的战争，其中谁会输从来没有任何疑问，但他们进行了很好的战斗。是的。悲伤，不是吗？无论如何，抱歉，我们在本期播客中变得相当多愁善感，汤姆。不，我不这么认为。我认为我们正在庆祝这个故事中非凡的东西，以及双方的勇气品质，并试图强调这一点，而不是其中的恐怖、背叛和肮脏。好的。所以他在兰德尔堡待了两年，什么也没做。然后在1883年，事情突然看起来好转了，因为他得到消息说他要被
Wow. I mean, that is a very, very expensive war in which there was never any doubt as to who was going to lose, but they put up a good, good fight. Yeah. Sad, isn't it? Anyway, sorry, we're getting quite maudlin in this podcast, Tom. No, I don't think so. I think we are celebrating what is extraordinary about this story and the qualities of courage on both sides and trying to perhaps emphasize that rather than the horror and the treachery and the squalor of it. Okay. So he's been in Fort Randall two years doing nothing. And then in 1883, it suddenly looks like things are looking up because he gets the news that he's going to be
释放了。他永远不知道为什么。他不知道为什么他是一个囚犯，他不知道为什么他们突然决定释放他，但他要回去了，他可以去立岩，开始新的生活。坐牛，一艘汽船到达接他。那艘汽船叫“W.J.比安号”，令人难以置信的是，驾驶那艘汽船的家伙和泰瑞将军在小大角战役前喝好酒时驾驶那艘汽船的家伙是同一个人。坐牛上了那艘船，他们沿着密苏里河向上游走。每一站，都有人渴望见到坐牛。他是一个完全的名人。他有点在说，你好，你打赌。是的。他唯一能说的东西。他在签他的名字。
released. He never knows why. He doesn't know why he was a prisoner he doesn't know why they've suddenly decided to release him but he's going to go back he can go to standing rock and start a new life sitting bull and a steamboat arrives to pick him up the steamboat is called the wj bian and unbelievably the guy who was piloting the steamboat is the same guy who had piloted the steamboat that General Terry had had his fine wines on before the Battle of the Little Bighorn. Sitting Bull gets on this boat and up they go up the Missouri. And every stop, there are people who are desperate to see Sitting Bull. He's a complete celebrity. And he's kind of saying, hello, you bet. Yeah. The only things he can say. And he's signing his autograph.
是的。他有这个非常有价值的签名。所以人们等不及了。他现在可以签自己的名字了。所以他在签他的签名。人们非常兴奋。他们为此付钱。所以他有很多钱。最后，在1883年5月，他到达了立岩保留地。
Yes. He has this incredibly valuable autograph. So people can't wait. He can sign his own name now. So he's signing his autograph. People are very excited. They pay for it. So he's got lots of money. And finally, in May 1883, he arrives at the Standing Rock Reservation.
所以这是应许之地吗？这是他麻烦的终点吗？汤姆，我们将在下一集毁灭性的剧集中找到答案。所以如果你是一个常客，那集很快就会出来。但如果你等不及了，你知道怎么做。therestishistory.com。你可以立即在那里得到它。但无论如何，在这个可怕的故事中，我们还有很长的路要走。鬼舞，伤膝河大屠杀，实际上是我们做过的最非凡的事情中的一些。
So is this the promised land? Is this the end of his troubles? We will find out, Tom, in the next devastating episode. So that will be coming out very soon if you're a regular listener. But if you can't wait, you know the drill. The rest is history.com. You can get it there immediately. But either way, we still have a way to go on this terrible story. The ghost dance, the massacre of Wounded Knee, some of the most extraordinary things actually we've ever done.
布法罗·比尔。是的，布法罗·比尔。还有很多要来。所以我们到时见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
Buffalo Bill. Yeah, Buffalo Bill. Lots to come. So we'll see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
我们一起主持《娱乐的其余部分》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦的固定节目。在我们的问答环节，我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、奖励剧集和现场门票的提前预订，
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
前往therestisentertainment.com。那是therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击逐字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。